all right guys so we have blessing here
say hi to the people what's up so
blessing you worked for me now for how
long a year and something like that a
year yeah cuz you were you he was
part-time at first yep and then he just
he moved into fulltime real quick
because he was just very talented just
happened sometimes it happens I'll
actually I'll tell you what happened
I'll tell you what happened no no we're
not I wasn't even going to tell that
part but but um I'll tell you what
happened so basically blessing was um
training
someone and he he like subbed for my
other producer at the time and um the
day he subbed he fixed all of my
problems like in one day it was like
amazing it was like it was like he he
could do a call-in show it was every
problem he he just figured out and I was
like he he can he can stay yeah and from
that they've been here since yeah yeah
so I I there's a lot of talk on the
internet about a very terrible work
conditions how have you survived through
them Yo
like heat in Miami is my problem you
know what I mean slies to Vegas is my
problem as
well no they've said they've said um you
have a slave contract is that n I'm okay
guys don't worry about me no that that's
what they're saying I don't need to be
freed
like some of you I need to free some of
you from so crazy how did it work out
for for the people that you know to be
honest I don't know cuz they have not
showed up on my
feet okay okay okay but anyway so tell
me what what is the past what's it like
being like behind the scenes um for all
this these crazy moments like people get
it we've had the police called um we
kicked people off the show get crazy
yeah like what have what have you
learned from watching hundreds of shows
and meeting like hundreds of women a lot
of women are the same if not all yeah
it's actually crazy cuz I didn't have
this mindset before but now when you see
it it's like you can't run away from it
it's the truth and what about they all
say that we recruit like specific types
of women to get on the show n it's
actually random like tell is no Ino on
who is
coming there people that come that we
don't even want to be there no yeah
there was one chick that came and I came
in and I was this chick that made like
five videos about how much she hated me
and I turned to them I'm like why is
this here that's what I'm saying
like we have recruiters that just get
people to come on the show so there no
pre-selected for failure if they fail
it's because that's what they are okay
so wait hold on so what's your advice to
someone that wants to be like a producer
or wants to like do YouTube and like cuz
you are kind of interesting you're
people don't know this hold on but but
your family like didn't want you to do
production right they wanted you to go
into like healthare I come from Zimbabwe
and we have a bit more of a traditional
mindset so you're expected to go to uni
University College do like the more
traditional jobs doctor lawyer all that
me I've always been a creative from the
start so going into production is like
well my mom actually said you know hey
if you can make you work make your work
but I don't think that's the part that
she would say if she want it for me but
anyways you have to work hard like I
remember when when when I started a p I
was building the studio where the shows
were going on the six nights every day
we're doing a show Monday to Saturday it
was it was crazy it was hectic that I
literally had to like sleep in the
studio uh which worked out
well but we had to put in the extra
hours to make sure that everything gets
done so you can't be lazy you have to be
able to work even when no one's
working and you have to be to see the
bigger picture as
well and just put in the work like a lot
of people just don't want to put in the
work and network as well cuz that's how
you're going to get great jobs and also
you you have to be able to help people
like me I ended up with P really cuz I
was helping someone so if you are
passionate about what you do be
passionate about it don't put too much
you know expectations the things will
fall in place but you have to be
passionate and work hard for it and
what what
um oh what's it like like you know being
behind the scenes
like with like do you do you get
backlash from your community at all like
you know working where you work nah not
the Zim
Community I'm from zimb there's no
backlash for my country no but I've had
backlashes from other communities but
not to mention which ones they know who
they are you know but there's no
backlash like your family your sisters
no nothing n no they all happy for me
you know what I
mean don't if watch the content
though but I don't think there's any
problems for my community anyways uh
it's great work that we do at just bir
there's a lot of hard workers there and
that was a great bus I'm I'm going to
say
that yeah I pay him to I get paid well
I'm never complain about that wait so um
no so how has the switch been so like 6
months ago roughly we switched you from
doing like production and now you help
manage how is that I mean this it's
different be it's been terrible for me I
hate it it's a different Beast I'll tell
you that but I'm always out for a
challenge any that's how I ended up here
cuz I'm always up for a challenge some
people give up and say this not for me
me I say okay how can I make become
better if this this job that's I've been
given or elevated to so we we are we are
not the best yet but we are working hard
don't it you know what's interesting too
I feel like the best people like cuz I
don't know about you I just always had
the mindset of like developing skills
yeah and I never really cared about like
even the way I question people I really
think it's from my two years in sales
like I I really do because back then it
was like a terrible job but I just told
myself I was going to learn this skill
and that's it you got to have as many
skills as possible me I came from a
church background I told myself how to
play all instruments move from there I
told myself how to do this camera stuff
production stuff but I put myself in POS
positions to learn and you might fail
but don't be scared of failure cuz if
you fail you're going to learn something
from it and it's actually better for you
to fail cuz that means you know how to
solve that problem for next time so
that's why I can tell people it's going
to happen you're going to fail something
things it's going to be hard you're
going to want to give up but the minute
you do that that's the end yeah well
guys that's
blessing you know thanks for this
interview he was camera shy for a while
but he's he's D I'm man I woke with P
out here so my times I'm like there's no
point you know what I mean someone is
see me somewhere so might as well but
anyways shout out to Zimbabwe we are out
here you know Miami
working